Einstein's general theory of relativity
describes gravity in terms of warps and
curves in space and time and it's the
time part that shows us that a certain
kind of time travel is allowed by the
equations of the general theory of
relativity let me describe how that goes
so imagine that we have a region of
space and we've got a spaceship and to
keep track of time we're going to put a
clock on the ship and a corresponding
one back on earth and now we're going to
go on a journey we're going to take the
ship and go to the edge of a black hole
careful not to fall over the edge so we
just hang out near the edge of the black
hole and Einstein tells us the time
elapsed is more slowly in the presence
of a strong gravity field a strong
gravitational potential which means when
the ship comes back there's a time
difference between the two clocks in
this case a 30-year time difference
between them so if a person gets out of
the ship and revisits with his or her
friends on earth that person will find
that their friends are 30 years older
relative to the amount that he or she
has aged for this person it's 2050
everyone on earth says it 2080 that is
time travel to the future courtesy of
general relativity and in this case time
spent near the edge of a black hole this
is not at all controversial everyone who
understands general tivity agrees that
at least in principle this is how things
work the deep question though is what
about getting back can you travel back
in time and the thing is we do not know
the answer to that question most of us
think it's not possible but it's
interesting that there are some
proposals that have been put forward for
how you just might be able to travel
back in time and let me describe one of
them to you it involves the idea of
what's known as a wormhole you may have
encountered that in other settings a
wormhole is just a tunnel through space
that acts like a shortcut so if
want to go from this location to this
location you can go the long route on
the outside or you can go the short
route through the wormhole itself now
let's rerun that little scenario of a
rocket going to the edge of a black hole
but now in the presence of a wormhole so
we bring in a rocket ship imagine it
control the mouth of a wormhole toward
the edge of a black hole and if we do
that we'll find just as we did a moment
to go the time elapsed is more slowly
near the edge of a black hole then far
away so if this ship then returns to the
vicinity of Earth by the time it gets
back to its starting point they'll be a
time difference between the two clocks
again in this case a 30-year time
difference just as we found before
now notice for the moment the wormhole
hasn't really played any role it just
went along for the ride what we're now
going to do is analyze exactly the same
situation but take the perspective of
looking through the wormhole itself to
see how time hooks up through the
wormhole from one opening to the other
so let's do exactly the same experiment
take that wormhole opening tow it to the
edge of the black hole but now what
we're going to do is I mention is look
through the wormhole itself and the math
shows that the two clocks at each
opening of the wormhole when viewed
through the wormhole itself agree with
one another there is no time difference
between them and that's quite
interesting because it means that when
this rocket ship goes back to the
vicinity of the earth if we now consider
the two clocks the one at this Mount
wormhole opening and the clock at that
wormhole opening those two clocks will
agree with one another so what we've
done is we've looked at one in the same
situation from two different
perspectives the first perspective was
looking at how time hooks up outside of
the wormhole where we found a 30-year
time difference and the second
perspective looked at how time hooks up
through the wormhole where we
no time difference at all now it's not
that one of these is right in the others
wrong they're both correct just
analyzing the same situation from two
different viewpoints and that's where
the power comes from because imagine we
started earth at may 2080 and we go on a
journey from one wormhole opening to the
other and now we want to go through the
wormhole itself which means we need to
invoke this picture the relevant one for
time going through the wormhole so we
start here we go into this picture and
we go through the wormhole itself and
we'll end up near Earth at may 2050 we
started at may 28 in your earth we wound
up at may 2015 near Earth
we've gone 30 years into the past time
travel into the past now the reason I
say this is speculative is that we don't
know if wormholes are real they do solve
the equations of general relativity but
that doesn't mean they're actually out
there in the universe and even if they
are real nobody knows if you could pass
through a wormhole they seem to be
unstable objects the math team to
suggest you need some sort of exotic
material to pry the throat of wormhole
opening so that it won't collapse in on
itself so with those two caveats in
place we don't know if we're moulds are
real we don't know if they're stable we
at least come to this surprising
conclusion that it's at least possible
that time travel to the past might be
something within the laws of physics I
should say most of us think that when we
understand physics better we're going to
find some way to rule this out but as of
today it's still at least a tiny
possibility that time travel to the Past
might actually be something that could
be accomplished
you